Let's cheers
to Bobby Fischer, yeah?
- Here's to Bobby B.
F.
- Check.
- Mate.
- [chuckles]
- Hello.
I'm Rich Fulcher,
and today we're gonna talk
about Bobby Fischer,
King of the Chess People.
It's 1972.
Bobby Fischer is, like,
29 years old,
and at the time, he had won
the U.S. Open Championship
and was
an International Grandmaster.
But he wasn't just
a normal chess player.
He was going,
put, put, put, put, put, check!
Woot, woot, woot, checkmate!
That was when he felt
most comfortable in life.
And yet, Russia had won
the World Championship
for the last 24 years.
Like, Russia, Russia,
Russia, Russia,
can--Russia!
And Russia used that
as sort of a PR campaign,
like, we are the kings.
We are not only Communists,
but we are
the intellectuals of the world
because we do chess.
The World Championships
are in Iceland,
and Boris Spassky, backed by
the Russian government,
was like, Bobby Fischer
is too young and inexperienced
for someone like me,
the World Champion.
Here's the thing,
Fischer hated Russians,
and he called them
filthy pigs.
So it was much more
than just a chess match.
The Cold War is happening.
Life Magazine called it
the match of the century,
and in the retrospect it was,
because it was the match
of the century.
And then
Fischer didn't show up.
He was still in,
uh, New York, and he said,
I don't want to play
in this match
'cause it's not enough
prize money.
It's not enough!
He was all talk.
He wasn't, like,
ready to perform
for, like, magic people.
But he gets a phone call
from Henry [bleep] Kissinger,
the Secretary of State,
and he said,
uh...hi, this is Ken--
This is Henry Kissinger
saying that you need to get
your butt over to Iceland now.
So he finally shows up
in Iceland,
and Spassky's like, fine,
great, let's get started.
But Fischer was like,
there's too many cameras.
There's, uh--
the audience is too close.
The chess board is too shiny.
The lights are shiny.
But Fischer
finally agreed to play,
and in America
it was shown on bars
throughout the country.
So you would go
into a bar,
you'd see chess and not
the New York Mets,
not the...Klondike...Bars.
- But what would you do
for a Klondike?
- I would do anything
for a Klondike Bar,
except Wikipedia my dingus.
- [laughs]
- And so,
the World Championship
was a best out of 24 match.
The first game was weird
because there's
cameras everywhere.
[whimpering gibberish]
It was like,
they're too close!
And Fischer made
a rookie move,
like, he went and got
an outlier pawn
with his bishop,
and Spassky surrounded it
with his bishops.
Whoa.
And he lost big time.
The second match came around,
and Spassky was there,
and he goes, where is he?
Fischer was staying
in his room and saying,
I will not go out
unless the cameras change.
And he was thinking
that they would do it,
but they didn't.
And then Fischer
forfeits the match.
Hrrump!
That's how they did it.
And he's down two-nothing,
which is pretty [bleep] bad.
Pfft-pfft-pfft.
- Why is all the ice gone?
Where did all the ice go?
- I just want some free flowers.
What?
- All the ice was put
into the cooler.
- Let me tell you
about the ice.
You just gotta mix it up!
- Jeez.
- Here's the thing.
The thing is--
- No, but what
the thing is, is, um,
I have a flaming dick disease.
[laughter]
No, I was trying to say
that to be behind two-nothing
is a big deal
in these matches.
And then finally
for the third game
Fischer said, look,
let's go to a back room
with no cameras, please.
And Spassky said yes.
Fischer felt comfortable
and won.
He won!
The first time he'd ever
beaten Fas--Fassko--
no, Spassky.
Once he won,
it just changed.
It's like a turnaround.
It's like
a blip, blah, aghhhh.
It's like a shhh.
It's like a pup.
It's like a poosh.
It's like a boo-laah!
Like a put-chi-sha-sha-snoot!
It happened.
So Fischer won
the third game,
the fifth game,
the sixth game,
the eighth game,
the tenth game.
It was so brilliant,
Spassky actually stood up,
he gave a standing ovation.
Thank you, thank you.
And after the 13th game,
the Soviets were like,
what do we do?
They went to the officials
and said,
Bobby Fischer is using
electronic devices
to wane Spassky's energy
through electronic
zappage.
So the Reykjavik police
from Iceland
came in and took apart
everything.
They took apart
Bobby Fischer's chair,
Bobby Fischer's, uh...
peanuts.
Peanuts.
And they were thinking,
oh, this is gonna
fluster Fischer,
because Fischer's very,
you know, tumultuous.
It didn't at all.
He loved it.
And he won after that,
and won and won,
and pretty much
after the 21st match,
it became
mathematically impossible
for Spassky to win.
And it was like, oh, my God!
Fischer wins!
And it's--he--
he's, like,
the World Chess Champion,
and he's from the U.S.
He walks out in Reykjavik,
there's people everywhere.
He's mobbed.
Fischer was huge,
and he became
a Cold War hero,
and he felt like...
[making guttural noises]
Tell me more,
you sucking pig!
Suck!
That's that.